foreign
[Music]
thank you
my father would drive me out he was
incident my father was sometimes here
sometimes not here he was really gone
from the time he was about four but he'd
show up from time to time and take me
out for a ride in the car with a rumble
seat but we drive out towards Newark
Airport and it was called Shantytown
and there would be a couple of Acres
of tents and you'd see little bonfires
and there were men
who had left their homes or they
couldn't support their families and
they weren't vagrants because they lived
there
and these were people who didn't have
any money
and they had shame it was a lot of Shame
the um
the depression if there's another word
to use to describe it was
it was fraught with shame
times was so bad
for everybody and so we were no
different I remember at one time my
mother
said to my father he was a cab driver
there's no milk on the table once you go
out and hack
bring in some money
he says nobody's getting in taxis these
days they can't afford it she says go
out hold up a bank
my father went out and now and a half
later came back he threw a quarter on
the table
he said here
buy some milk
he started to cry
and my mother would sit there and look
at him someday
watching
watching him smoke a cigar
he said who do you think you are with
the cigar Rockefeller
she came over and she broke the cigar
from that point on my father smoked a
pipe
[Music]
all comedy comes out of tragedy
which is you know it's a shock it's a a
social shock and it's a terrible thing
for people to just have
the rug pulled up
but that's when human creativity
Sprouts it's Forest
[Music]
have to do something about this gotta
eat
so where we start
they used to say my father couldn't work
that was the they called that stock
lines everybody used the same line he
couldn't work there was no food in the
house we couldn't pay the rent
and the landlord was going to dispossess
us and then came the depression
and people left it was created from that
period New York October 1929 everything
was calm and peaceful in this great City
then suddenly the bottom dropped out of
Wall Street
but where the broker discouraged no they
knew Prosperity was just around the
corner some preferred white bread some
whole wheat others rise the birds had
little choice
I was born an orphan
I didn't have any home so I was one of
the kids who grew up coming out of
absolute poverty I didn't have any
future I didn't know what I wanted to be
so I started hitchhiking across the
country to see what would happen this
was in 1929 in June
and I hitchhiked up the coast to Walla
Walla Washington and then I wanted to
cross the Rockies and that was tough on
hitchhiking so I started becoming a hobo
on railroads I rode freight trains
across the country always kept going I
had no money whatsoever with me maybe
five dollars
and uh
every time there was a job offered I
took it whatever I knew what to do with
it or not
two bucks a day for this all I have to
do is walk them down from the light I
don't know
it's your regular job no no I don't
believe in regular jobs I do this for a
friend of mine I sub for him on his
night off
and all you got to do is walk up and
down here that's all
is it all right if I walk him down with
you sure it's a free country in it
I got to New York
I was sleeping in the YMCA gym in
Brooklyn
and it was a job open as a typist and I
was on Wall Street and I was working
away at it every day in August and July
and then Along Came October
and this was a great turning point of my
life
on October 29 1929
the depression the Great Depression
started
[Music]
and they couldn't keep up with the way
the markets were falling and prices were
changing you couldn't sell your stock
even if you wanted to and you knew it
was going down because you couldn't get
the you couldn't get the thing the
message through everything was jammed of
the the people in the office at the
National City Bank of New York where I
worked were all crying because they'd
all invested all of their savings on
them and On The Wall Street wherever you
looked the boys and girls were men and
women were wondering what was ever going
to happen to them and I was wondering a
little about it but I was wondering that
since the time I was born so I had an
advantage over the rest of them
contending with modern economic
difficulties requires quite as high
courage and as much Enterprise as was
displayed by men and women of colored
wagon days
[Music]
I was born in Brooklyn New York
a boarding house table
and my father had come from Glasgow
Scotland was in the first world war and
he became a a comic and I stayed in in
Burlesque at the time
their people wanted to laugh there was
nothing to laugh about and they got
together and said let's have a burlesque
show so what's that Jesus gags and
dance group and this and that
my mother brought me to California
she in a broken down car and she said
I've Got a Feeling
my son wants to be
so we traveled and we there were no
motels or anything we slept on dirty
dirty mattresses
it wasn't easy and
no roads
no Maps
are we on the way to California I think
it's down that way
it was rough on my
[Music]
mother I remember being born
so I have a total recall of all of my
life
when I was 19 years old I went to the
Greyhound bus to get on the bus and
looked in the united cigar store window
and there was a copy of a book there
called Grapes of Wrath by John Steinbeck
I bought The Grapes of Wrath got on the
bus and rode through the Dust Bowl
on Highway 66
reading about in the book the book was
something and Steinbeck spoke to me so
when I wrote The Martian Chronicles
I borrowed the ideas for the Martian
Chronicles from The Grapes of Wrath
I remember trying to think about how I
could take my bicycle and how I could
put some wings on the sides of it maybe
get a little bit of lift as I pedaled
along and of course I built cockpits out
of
orange crates and and cans and things
that resemble the throttle and here I'd
never even been in an airplane but but
it was uh
uh kind of
make-believe and in those days you
listen to The Shadow and the creaking
door and you you didn't have the
imagination stolen from you by the
visuals of Television you had to imagine
all these things
the the thing that was amazing about the
times that we'll never see them again
was that people were in my opinion
heroically passive they just took
whatever life handed them
they obeyed the law as much as possible
except when it came to feeding their
families then they would steal or they
would do anything that they had to do to
survive
I remember stealing food that spring
home I remember looking behind the
markets the garbage cans looking for for
like like head lettuce and it still had
some good leaves on them uh you know we
did those things to stay alive
and my father took off
and my mother remarried and The
Stepfather who was the kind of had that
kind of ethic that the man worked you
know the woman cooked the man worked and
there was no work
there was no work and that impacted on
him and he turned just vicious
suffering from that so the whole family
unit suffered in so many ways
the Great Depression of the 1930s is is
not just another commodity bubble or
Price bubble it's it it the reason it
was so deep and lasted so long is
because there was a convergence of so
many things happening there was the
great bubble in stock prices of course
the 1920s that's what causes the stock
market crash but we've seen stock market
crashes of kind of comparable
proportions without the ensuing great
economic chaos so there's something more
and deeper at work here in the 1930s and
to be honest about it economic
historians do not agree to this day
about exactly what happened
I remember when the banks closed in 32
and and my mother called my brother and
me and we were all playing in the yard
she said I have bad news and I thought
maybe a cherished relative had died or
something and and she said the banks
have closed and you will not see the
money that you have in the bank anymore
because we'll probably never get it back
we didn't have social security we didn't
have a lot of the things that people
have to date you know to guide them
through rough times
so it was uh I mean you were totally on
your own I was guessed I was about 11
years old 1936 when a lot of people came
to California from Oklahoma and that you
know the Dust Bowl but growing up in the
area
uh
we'd like some of our friends we would
like to see we were poor but we didn't
know it because everybody was poor
I think maybe the Okies made it because
of sheer determination but if you didn't
have any money and you didn't have a car
you didn't have any how are you going to
make that move it was too tough although
I do know one family who made it very
successfully in Canada and they told me
stories of how they piled I think five
or six kids the mother and the father of
the car with all their Earthly
belongings with frying pans are still
hanging from the sides of the car just
like the Oakies did and they stopped off
in little places and eventually one son
was deposited to Regina another
Saskatoon another one in Calgary they
each try to make their own way in
various parts of Canada
it was you know Charles Dickens once
roasted it was the best of times it was
the worst of times believe me it was the
worst of times
people were walking around without
eating
there's no need to talk a history of
what happened in terms of the very
famous Rich who you know what happened
to them
but
the real the real
you felt like the country was going down
[Music]
we lost our house in 1933
and they were thrown out on the street
and
certainly is one of the most awful
moments of my life ever
[Music]
and my father was not a
worldly man when everybody was making
money in the stock market and everybody
was saying
people were saying gee Joe what are we
what do you do with your mind I got it
he was keeping it in the house hidden
and I said you know that's crazy
I was compared down invested well he
didn't know so he invested in 1928 I
think he invested in electric Bond and
share an Anaconda Copper and of course
he bought on the margin as everybody did
I mean that's what they they thought
that was the way to do it and they were
encouraged to do it
by the brokers
and when everything collapsed we lost
everything and then we
my father was never the same man
[Music]
and we were having lunch
and a man that they knew
the man at the bank who had the
mortgages came in
and he said what are you people doing
here
and my mother said I'm not going to
mention his name because he still has
family in Wilkes-Barre my mother said Mr
X we're having our lunch would you like
to sit down and have something to eat
and he said you can't have lunch here
this is not your house this is my house
my father just by this time was just
gone he just
and my mother said my mother's a very
strong woman very brave woman and she
said
well Mr AXA
it's our house we live here it's our
house he said look it's not your house
and he went and he spit on the rug
and with that I mean everybody just the
family just collapsed and we were herded
out of the house our furniture was taken
out everything was taken out of the
house put on the street most of which
disappeared shortly thereafter we went
my mother had a sister
was married to a very decent man who's
an old socialist and didn't believe in
the stock market or you know profiting
by anybody else's labor and he had a
small furniture store in West Pittston
Pennsylvania
and uh
we want to live with them
I grew up in the depression but when you
have nothing to contrast it with and all
your neighbors are living the same way
you don't know you're in a great
depression or even a mild depression
but one of our saving Graces and I think
this is true of many people around that
time in a rural or a semi-rural area
we had a very big Garden which was twice
as big as our house
and we raised a whole lot of vegetables
and so all summer we're living out of
the garden and in a sense food is free
in that way
we raised chickens we had 25 chickens we
didn't kill them very often because then
you don't have as many eggs
and I one of my chores was to gather all
the eggs which happened daily
and the family could need more than six
or eight ten eggs a day
and so we would give them to neighbors
and it wasn't like I'll give you this if
you give me that it was just here take
some eggs and then other times they
bring you milk if they had a cow
that's how these programs work in the
third world countries or they give a
family a goat and that's not just they
have milk
they get enough milk for neighbors and
in that way they can barter for other
things and sometimes you even start a
small business like a little dairy or
something
curiosity and challenges is what
I think this work ethic produced
you had to move on and you had a you had
to be creative you had to have a
creative mind
foreign
[Music]
but it ain't going to be this way all
the time
the depression
was a depression in the
physical
economic sense
but in the social and the cultural in
the spiritual sense
it was a stimulation
struggle and strife and Trauma and
tragedy are great sources of our
greatest strengths and one way is that
in current evolutionary thinking our
basic social Tendencies to to cooperate
to trust to uh to sacrifice and to give
are are a product of our Collective
sociality responding to
struggle and and and threat right and so
when we enter into historical times
where there is resource deprivation or
there are threats it's it turns that on
and people feel routinely you know in
the Great Depression or during wartime
or during you know uh economic troubles
people feel immediately this bonding
tendency that's a great product of times
of strife even now we are not so much
divided as we are disconnected
if we just get power come from
connection
plugging in
and you receive power
so I enjoy
connecting I have a hundred and six God
children
including
the president
he is one of my God children
a hundred and six you know what cause I
listen
I pray with him I talk with him I give
them directions we got to go back to
being parents
my daddy just didn't and Mama didn't
raise me
everybody in my community raised me
I remember you
you know in those days people would help
each other
you know if this person had something
you didn't have you know you you traded
for it or give it to you know
you know that really brings us the best
in people I opened my first official gym
in Oakland
in 1936
. Sam was the first one to have women
working out with the weights I was the
first one to have old people working out
with the weights I was the first one of
the athletes working out with the
weights the word he got about that
Jackson he's a nut he's a crackpot you
know got women working out with the ways
to get athletes working out with those
the athletes they'll get muscle bound
the old guys will drop a heart attack
you can't believe what I went through
boy it was tough not only to open the
first gym and everything but then going
through the depression
so people had no money
but that's how I started
see I wasn't thinking of depression I
was thinking of helping people
uh
[Applause]
is this a racket I ask you
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
I got a job in 1929 as I just graduated
from high school as a messenger at
Salomon brothers and Hustler
I was one of the few people who got out
of Wall Street in time because
by September 1st I had to go to college
so I got out of Wall Street and was out
of it for four years
my father was a
insurance broker and agent
and had a small business with very few
employees and one day he came home we
sat down at dinner and he said I just
had to fire someone and it's really
upset me terribly
and at that point he broke into tears
I had never seen my father cried
Illinois days Ben didn't cry you know
you weren't supposed to show your
feelings though all the nonsense that
prevails but I've never forgotten that I
mean it upset him terribly
and that he had to fire some this man
because and he had to because he didn't
have the income
in order to pay the salary
he was just or else he couldn't have
brought home enough money to feed us
in 1945 in November I came back from the
war and I was in my Air Force uniform
still I went back home see my mother and
father
we're driving around and I suddenly look
in the corner of the bank
and there I see Mr X and I said hey hold
it up for a minute will you I was 23
years old and I was just in great shape
I walked into the bank and I said Mr X
do you remember me and he said no no
what is it he said I'm busy
and I said oh just this
and I spit
and he stood up and I hit him
and it was and crazy it was just one of
those crazy moments out of the Durant I
was smiling and I looked and everybody
was like this nobody moved nobody
stopped me he was on the floor I said
that's what you did to my mother and
father
it was the most satisfying day of my
life
ever ever still to this day
there was a guy down the street who had
a candy store candy store was always the
center of life
and his name was Joe he was a very good
looking guy
always had a smile on his face he wore
nice clothes
and the nice thing about Joe was if you
those days of Daily News was two cents
and I think on Sunday was a nickel or
whatever it was and uh you came in on
Saturday
and you got the Brooklyn section but you
didn't have to pay for the for the paper
until you got there on Sunday
and Joe would always let you have the
Brooklyn section assuming that you would
get the rest of the paper on Sunday and
pay the rest of the money
so he was like you know sweetest man in
the world
one day we woke up
the store was closed what happened
Joe hunt himself
it was I mean really I mean it still
comes back because why
I don't know couldn't pay the rent
whatever it was
uh those were some of the things that uh
happened I think to so many people at
that time everybody had a story
[Music]
from the time that the United States
entered the era of the Industrial
Revolution the early 19th century there
were periodic gigantic swings in the
business cycle and what were called
commonly depressions in the 1830s the
1850s the 1870s the 1890s a pretty sharp
one in 1921 although it was quite brief
so the Great Depression of the 1930s is
not all that unfamiliar an episode
except it's grander in scale and it
lasts longer than the previous ones and
there has been nothing comparable to it
since you know it was just an abysmal
event it was essentially a lost decade I
mean there's a lot of workers uh in
their Prime working years that you know
lost 10 12 15 years of a work history
because of that
um you know it's almost like a murder
mystery you know we all have our
favorite whodunits
um and and the Great Depression is
really about you know who killed the
economy there was a whole generation of
great economists who were
brought into the economics profession
precisely because they perceived that
something had gone very wrong with our
economic system and they wanted to
understand what had gone wrong and
furthermore try to figure out how to fix
it so that sort of thing wouldn't happen
again and the key to preventing a Great
Depression is making your financial
institutions fireproof if you like it
used to be we built our cities entirely
of wood we crowded everybody together
and you could have things like the Great
Fire of London at the end of the 17th
century devastates a huge amount of the
city and a lot of people you know lose
lose their belongings and and many of
them lose their lives so you want to
build something much more like a modern
city which has different kinds of
structures more fire breaks more fire
houses more fire engines
and that's what we want to do with our
financial system also
there is no natural process which
updates our regulations it historically
something goes badly wrong and then we
recognize that regulation
got behind you know when we have these
These Times of Crisis you know it's
particularly important to think about
all of these different dimensions I
think that most of the economic policy
debates have focused on
how do you deal with regulating
financial markets and so forth and
that's very important but you need to go
beyond that to how do you have a more
durable society in which when crises do
happen you have
a better safety net for people's lives
if you're going to function you have to
be certain about some things
you have to be pretty certain about who
you trust who loves you where the next
meal is going to come from and what
you're going to do if it rains you have
to have that stuff figured out so that
you can take risks and grow and all the
other things that are so much fun to do
now when that stuff gets Disturbed
it's physically and emotionally
terrible
there's a wonderful study that the
research teams went around the country
doing these in-depth interviews and they
were trying to discover all kinds of
things about how the depression that
affected people psychologically there
was one consistent finding that they
found in case after case after case that
the unemployed man felt personally
guilty and ashamed and mortified
embarrassed humbled that he had been put
in this situation now we can look back
historically
and think well wait a minute this
unemployed man we're talking about here
should have looked around him and seen
there were 12 million 999 999 other
people unemployed and it wasn't that he
had suddenly personally failed or lost
his moral fiber but the reflex of all
kinds of unemployed people was to blame
themselves for their situation and not
to blame the system so this was an
impediment to a collective political
action it was something Franklin
Roosevelt remarked repeatedly to his
campaign Entourage during the
presidential campaign of 1932. he said
this is the worst crisis this country
has faced since the Civil War and why
aren't people in the streets why are
they rioting why aren't they demanding a
political response to this
[Music]
in contradiction to the popular notion
that the population of America was
passive for the most part during the
worst days of the Great Depression
the opposite was true in Chicago for
example among African Americans it was
not uncommon
in the First full year of the depression
the fan hundreds of black men assembling
in Washington Park on the South Side
discussing their plight and what they
should do about it in August of 1931
over a thousand people maybe five
thousand
marched on a home where a widow was
about to be set out by the police and
the sheriff's bailiffs and those
thousands of people prevented her
Furnishings from being put on the street
unfortunately
there was
a scuffle the police Drew their weapons
and killed three other demonstrators
whites joined blacks in a massive March
down South State Street that had over 30
000 Marchers parade past the funeral
home where the bodies of the three this
East Lake
you tie that in interracial marches with
the mid-1930s efforts of labor unions
who are organizing in the mass
production industries and you've got a
blending of interest and the overcoming
temporarily at least of uh past racial
uh tensions
[Music]
in the 30s and this sort of sets the
stage in the North
for Dr King being able to be successful
we created in a sense parallel
institutions
parallel social institutions
political institutions Economic
Institutions cultural institutions which
gave those of us who were young
a feeling that we could have fun and if
we were serious about the future we'd go
to school
we we though we were poor we were not
poverty stricken
and there's a difference one is a
condition in which you happen to be one
is an attitude that one day
things are going to change and you're
going to be the beneficiary if you just
continue
stay out of trouble
and get the kind of
qualifications educationally in other
ways that will be needed to change your
position so most of us of that
generation
at that time
did that
[Music]
I was born in the house and close to a
hospital celebrated hospitals uh just so
good at graveyard so from one to tomb we
Face segregation
and that meant not only separation also
meant restrictions
of access to education
and health care and job and development
so we lived in the shadows of the Great
Depression
so most blacks during that period either
knew living grandparents with big
enslavery oh there were many
ex-slaves were still alive so the least
educated
the most vulnerable
I had that took the greatest hit and is
it it's an intergenerational continuity
people who try to
slice and dice history
miss the fact that
God does not miss one day since you
start making days they're all connected
so much of the art of the 30s literature
and visual art is is rooted in an
interest in
understanding what's happening during
the Depression and particularly you know
at the outset of it when 25 of Americans
were unemployed and this is you know
this is a huge number and had a a
devastating impact on people's lives and
artists were responding to that impact
even the artists who were carried over
from the 1920s like Ernest Hemingway may
be the best example of this Hemingway
was writing about
individuals during the 1920s and the
problems of individuals in the 1930s
he is continues to write these kinds of
stories but then he writes a story about
the Spanish Civil War For Whom the Bell
Tolls
and he writes To Have and Have Not in
which in which the the main character
concludes after you know terrible uh
terrible events during the novel a man
alone doesn't have a chance
so this sense of the collective the need
for other people to depend upon on on
their fellows is something that comes up
uh in in that literature even in the
literature of people like Hemingway who
came in from the 20s it's very obvious
in literature Steinbeck of course who's
you know maybe the preeminent writer or
the one who
characterizes in in some ways
caricatures the whole culture of the 30s
[Music]
one of the few songs at that time that
really at least the broadway songs that
that really hits the depression full-on
I mean talks about it in no uncertain
terms brother can you Sparrow dime is a
very very powerful song written by Yip
harburg and Jay Gurney and both work
hard-carrying Communists I don't say
that it's disparagingly it's just a fact
but they were in Central Park trying to
think of a topic for a song and they ran
across a man or obviously a Harvard
educated an Ivy League man but he was
down in his luck he was wearing evening
clothes and he came up to up to them and
surprised them by saying brother can you
spare a dime and I thought that's that's
the great title that's the way the story
goes but it's a good song many ways
great words and it refers back of course
to World War One to the it's all about a
guy who was a soldier in World War one
and you know the American government
really did the dirty on on the on the
soldiers the Doughboys who'd fought in
World War one they promised them a bonus
at the end of the world they were
getting this money and they never gave
it to them and of course in the 1930s
when Hoover was still President we have
the famous Bonus Army marching right
their way across the country and setting
up their tents outside the White House
and the Army actually being brought in
to to drive them out I mean physically
violently drive them out but this song
directly talks about those soldiers once
in khaki suits G we look swell full of
that Yankee Doodle dumb half a million
boots when slogging through hell and I
was the kid with the drum I like that
line I say don't you remember they
called me Al I mean so that's a great
detail They Call Me Al it was Al all of
the time say don't you remember I'm your
pal brother can your spirit down very
powerful song to a minor key Eastern
European Jewish Melody I mean very
powerful stuff indeed but of course uh
harburg went on to write a piece of
put it fluff but certainly an Escapist
song Somewhere Over the Rainbow
you know you know like great all great
songwriters they can write all kinds of
material
oh we ain't got a barrel of money maybe
we're ragged and funny bubble travel
along singing a song side by side and
you know people
went on to sing that song in a very
jolly fashion
but actually the words are are very
touching and in fact Darkly touching and
the the verse which nobody knows
is um
see that sun in the morning
peeking over the hill I bet you know it
always has I guess it always will that's
how I feel about someone somebody feels
about me we know we love each other and
that's the way it'll always be
and then it goes on with the we ain't
got a barrel of money maybe we're ragged
and funny we'll travel along singing a
song side by side
you know if I have my honey
you know we just stick together and have
spunk we'll we'll make it and it
actually comes out of the music even
more than I ever realized you know I
realize in my shows you know halfway and
I'll let everybody know you know
this got everybody through the
Depression last time
where do you live we moved
from where uh near my aunt's house
oh you see uh my aunt lived a little bit
away from where we used to live she's a
widow
her husband died that's how she came to
be a widow
the stock market didn't kill him
no he's the one that the stock market
didn't kill he died in September BC
before the crash very sick man he had
diabetes at 45. that's nothing I had
Chrysler at 110.
Eddie cant it was really one of the
people who really changed our lives
because he was on radio on Sunday nights
at eight o'clock and when he got on the
air
during the worst parts of the depression
when people have no jobs there's no food
on the table he would sing like
potatoes are cheaper tomatoes are
cheaper Now's the Time to fall in love
he was encouraging people to fall in
love
oh well that was nice but he himself had
gone through a very tough time he lost
his home he lost his money and they were
moving furniture out of his house and he
was still able to go on radio and start
cheering people up for those few minutes
that we saw those guys do their stuff
the whole world was full of Hope
see by cracking that reminds me
has forgot to remember listen
it's time you folks have to give a
present to a bride and groom
be sure you make that present in Aladdin
kerosene Madeleine now they can Court in
the dark before they get married
you know after a while they get fed up
on him they need a little light that
letter from a fellow says here he had a
fallen out with his gal and he he wrote
me one with the thing I only want a
buddy not a sweetheart
I'll sing it for him but I bet a dollar
he changes his money
what is romance but taking a chance
so that's a good example of a early
broadcast now these were called
syndicated shows uh they're 16 inch
transcriptions uh each 15 minutes per
side
and these were pressed out by uh
whoever put them out for the sponsor and
they were sent out to whatever radio
stations subscribed and wanted to play
these shows
and this quite obviously was very uh as
aimed at a rural population and a
population that would be interested in
buying lamps because they they didn't
have electricity at that point
uh this is a sample of a show from the
Coconut Grove Orchestra here in in Los
Angeles which was the preeminent
nightclub certainly on the west coast
and then one of the the world's you know
prominent nightclubs uh so here's how
the here's what the better half would be
listening to so to speak listen chatting
music has thrilled your favorite star
and guided their dancing feet in gay
fantasy
thank you foreign
out in the Farms some people have to
depend on lamps for their lighting here
in Los Angeles another department
Metropolitan centers
even during the depths of the depression
people were still having a good time you
know it was not as though the entire
population was destitute or anything
like that you know it it certainly
affected some people more than others my
uncle by the way was a songwriter at
that time his name is Stanley Demerol
and he was writing in the depths of the
1930s depression in England and he he
wrote songs of a complete escapism that
one of them is sung today he wrote Lady
of Spain I adore you and let's all sing
like the bird is sing and he once
explained why he wrote this song he said
well he said my partner and I said we
couldn't compete with these American
slick American love songs that always
seem to take place on a couch indoors so
my partner and I decided we need to do
songs that were about the outside like
Lady of Spain and my uncle told me that
things were so bad that some of his
songwriting colleagues and you have to
listen very carefully to this
some of his colleagues were forced to
pawn pawn their own underwear which is
something you can't get much lower than
that pawning your underwear
among the rugged Peaks that frowned down
upon the Bargo pass are found crumbling
castles of a bygone age
oh Hollywood was at that time a little
town a little Country Town you know and
it was wonderful I loved it
the movies kept going
and well people needed something else
you know and you know their minds taken
off their
tragedy that goes on every day and until
they get jobs
for sixth sense for children and 11
cents for grown-ups there was a penny
tax
and I remember you standing in front of
the theaters and when an adult would go
in with their 15 cents they'd get four
pennies back and you'd say can I have
one of your pennies Mister to get into
the movie
and they most people gave you the penny
but every now and then some big sport
would give you four cents so you were
well on your way into the movie
and of course then once you got in
he opened the door down at the bottom
and let two or three of your friends in
and then there was a scramble always
because when you open the door the light
from The Outsiders are usually during
the course of his matinee the lake from
outside would come in and like ushers
would come scrambling to find the kids
who just got in there were the Coming
Attractions which we still have that's
all we have left of the way people used
to go to the movies but when they back
then they would see short subjects like
a comedy short with Laurel and Hardy
they might see a Serial chapter you know
a western that was continued next week
they might see a news reel they would
see a cartoon there were travelogues you
know they're all sorts of of these
subjects and people were just used to
that seeing a whole variety of different
shorts and then the big picture a full
feature movies in the 30s ran the gamut
from extreme poverty row things that
were guys making westerns for 900 bucks
you know there were big pictures like
With The Wind that were made for
multiple Millions
Studios were making 40 50 60 pictures a
year a star could make two or three or
four films a year directors the same so
today a filmmaker might make a film
every two or three years whereas John
Ford in 1939 1940 made six you know
major Classics that are considered today
young Mr Lincoln drums along the Mohawk
Grapes of Wrath how green was my valley
Stagecoach all within a very brief span
of time
and of course the musicals too you know
the gold diggers of 1932 and the 1933
and all the girls came out you know all
had blonde hair and all BuzzFeed
Berkeley dance routines very glamorous
and I grew up and we all did we all grew
up with this fantasy world
movies were important I saw things to
come in the film by H.D Wells it came
out in 1936 and when I saw that film I
staggered out of that film I said the
future is going to belong to me I'm
going to make the future
[Music]
for men no rest and no ending he must go
on Conquest Beyond Conquest
for a Humanities so fragile so weak
little little animals
little animals
and if we're no more than animals we
snatch each little scrap of happiness
and live and suffer and pass
it is this or that
all the universe for nothingness
which shall it be
which shall it be well one of the things
I think that has been misstated about
films of the 30s in the past is that
um
the movies provided escapism and it's
true there were a lot of things like
Fred Astaire and and musicals and
comedies WC Fields and Bob Hope and the
Marx Brothers provided Escapist
entertainment what's the show
there were just as many films perhaps
that dealt with the reality of the
depression but they have not been the
ones that have been revived because
they're some of them are pretty grim
The Wizard of Oz the book
and especially the movie were also about
monetary policy about deflation they're
not being enough money so the word Oz is
short for ounce there's the yellow brick
road the gold question which was so
Salient in that period
the very dark part in the beginning the
black and white part that's how people
felt about monetary policy they knew
there wasn't enough money but they also
knew they viewed it as like the weather
there's nothing they could do about it
it was like a storm coming and they just
had to weather it the character Dorothy
she finds her own way
this disastrous situation and he manages
sort of by locked his sleigh at least
one witch and then another by by
cleverness and she actually manages to
attain the wizard
so tame the money and that was kind of a
fantasy
everybody points to the 30s as a great
golden age of the filmmaking process
but remember that the great filmmakers
of the 30s they had learned their crafts
in silent films
the craft of visual storytelling
I remember my mentor Alfred Hitchcock
saying that with the Advent of sound we
lost the art form of the moving image
talkies came in there was a greater
sense of realism silent films had been
almost dreamlike in the way they
presented their stories and and sound
brought a realism to the movies and you
saw that manifested in things like
gangster pictures and backstage dramas
you saw more stories about Working Class
People as well as fantasy Escape things
with with Rich folks and Jeopardy
[Music]
away
people expected a cartoon with their
movie show you could have you could
leave out the newsreel you could leave
out the two real comedy but you had to
have a cartoon in fact there's a famous
1930s song that's called what no Mickey
Mouse what kind of program is this and
that was a song that was popular because
it was a theater theater didn't show a
cartoon that's what it was about
say yes
Disney was moving animation from this
what they call rubber hose crazy style
of of drawing to a more realistic style
of Storytelling and all the studios
followed Disney but in the early 30s the
depths of depression those cartoons are
particularly like psychedelic they're
they're mind-blowing
me
am I the
guy me me
there's no no realism here and the
stories themselves are sort of these
guys were just making it up as they went
along storytelling even as in a short
cartoon wasn't sophisticated as it would
be 10 years later when they made Bugs
Bunny cartoons and Daffy Duck cartoons
in this early 30s period they might
start the story in one place and go
outside and then suddenly they're going
somewhere else they just came up with
these stories and they would just you
know kind of draw them you know free
form you know Scream Of Consciousness
that's how they look
my food paycheck is from really paycheck
is from uh Walt Disney Studio
I was on Bambi for three and a half
years
so that was never ideal they didn't pay
me very much but then I love the job
[Music]
going back to the wa I remember yes
McDonald's right he was a director I
bought my painting and show it to him so
we get paid 96 a month so you turn turn
into oil painting and two watercolor or
L4 lithograph
a good thing that that saved a lot of
orders you know if I'm solving dead
the sensitive fingers of artists are
poorly suited to manual labor and in
finding suitable work for musicians and
other artists the WPA has contributed
greatly to the culture of America
painters too contribute their bit to
making the works program a real and
permanent accomplishment these
reproductions of the American scene of
today will make this one of the most
fertile periods of our countries are
[Music]
some of this work is done on canvas but
much of it is created on the walls of
our schools libraries and other public
buildings in the form of mural paintings
[Music]
the fact that the government would
experiment with the idea of
putting creative people to work and and
and getting a public good out of it was
really piloted here at Coit Tower in San
Francisco it really was the pilot
program that helped to launch the WPA
the works progress administration's use
of artists so the 26 artists who got
involved and were commissioned to create
these murals here at court tower
were really at the Pioneers sort of the
experiment that that worked and then it
allowed public art to spread across the
whole country it's a school of art
called social realism
and that most of what's depicted in in
these murals and social realism was
really about capturing everyday life and
helping to tell the story of the average
person
as opposed to just what you know the the
news and the media sort of uh would sort
of highlight back then and even today
which is the story of the great man
right the the captains of industry
and there is a an opportunity of
creating Community when you deal with a
lot of public art and that's certainly
been the philosophy of many of the
murals that we have been commissioned by
the Arts commission over the years here
in San Francisco
[Music]
we are at Lucy flower high school and
this is the foyer of the school and this
mural was created between 1938 and 1940
by Edward Millman he was an artist that
was on the WPA and he wanted to create a
mural about outstanding American women
and at the same time he was studying a
lot about the Mexican muralist movement
and prior to creating this he had
actually gone to Mexico and studied with
Diego Rivera in 1934. so when he was
sort of building the agenda for this
image he wanted to really promote that
kind of social realism within this sort
of Temple that you see here
it took him two years to complete this
image and then one year later it was
deemed by the Board of Education as
misery Laden and depressing so they
whitewashed it one year later this image
is probably the most controversial in
the city of Chicago because it was so
heavy and it was talking about so many
core truths to what was happening at the
time and you know the important thing to
remember is artists are like a barometer
of what's Happening they record what's
going on they tell these stories in
creative and imaginative ways
and when that kind of
philosophical and intellectual
creativity is covered up that's that's
something that is really hard to take
so when you walked into this room it was
completely white in 1996 and so we did
test after test to try to figure out how
to unveil this powerful image it was a
pretty magical time for us that was in
1997 and it took us about nine months to
move throughout this entire room and
then we had an unveiling ceremony and it
was all about unveiling the history that
it encapsulated so yes it was very
precious to all of us involved and
remained so
and one of the main themes that emerge
is in in the Arts of the 30s and the
whole culture of the 30s is is the one
that Hemingway eventually comes to
that the individual alone
doesn't have a chance
and so this idea that people need other
people
that the individual can be broken but
then maybe stronger but but but so much
of the of of the art of the period was
moving toward a sense and and the
politics of the period moving toward a
sense of the necessity politically for
empathy for care
for you know Brotherhood for Collective
action whether it's in strikes or in you
know the implementation of a social
security system
at the same time it's you know also
strongly resisted by by a whole other
you know political set so so the 30s
becomes a really polarized period
politically you know between uh you know
between these collectivist Notions and
the Notions of of the individual that
are still fairly strong
um in in this country
[Music]
[Applause]
you and you and you and you you've got a
president now he gave the land a new
deal you hold the Cardinal you heal you
and you and you and you put shoulders to
the plow he gave us what we asked for
now pay him back somehow step out in
front get back of the present and give a
man a job
Franklin Roosevelt's achievement is all
the more remarkable because he had not
only to invent the tools with which to
fight the depression but he had to
convince people that it was legitimate
to do anything at all and there are a
lot of people who were very very
skeptical that there was anything that
should be done here other than just let
the thing go down the drain and
eventually it would take care of itself
[Music]
foreign
there was a woman named Lorena Hickok
that was employed by the Roosevelt
administration to go around the country
and write reports about how people were
dealing with the economic difficulties
and you know what what she really came
to say and especially like in the farm
Bell in different parts of the country
is that she saw this kind of prevailing
sense of Despair you know people were
becoming apathetic you know and and I
think to a certain extent you know the
New Deal did play a role in kind of
letting people know you know we're not
going to let things continue and
continue on as they as they have then
you know we are going to try and improve
the situation and I think that meant a
lot to a lot of people well I remember
sitting by the radio whole family
sitting by the radio listening to a
fireside chat you know roosevelty
that the only thing we have to fear is
fear itself
[Music]
there's your doctor
foreign
[Music]
have confidence
wake up wake up open up the door
right off we'll come back with more
yesterday there were Skies of gray but
today is another day
[Music]
we'll all get the words
I think we'll win out not because of a
government
not even because of our leaders
but the cause as a people we've had a
vision and we've worked for it and we've
seen it through okay
the president of the United States
inspired by the way by his wife Eleanor
at least they inspired directors
but I don't know tended to want to give
to the community of Greater
opportunities than they had enjoyed
[Music]
open
thoughts opportunities about out of the
new deal
can we begin to create a Real Deal some
people felt that FDR was the closest
thing keeping us from having a
revolution in this country in other
words he was providing work with the WPA
and all these different projects that if
that would have happened there are those
who contended we would have had a bloody
Revolution so you had a lot of social
unrest at that time not like it was
necessarily over in Europe but you had
people that were out of work they were
hungry that they looked at fascism or
communism and that gave them that gave
them a chance an opportunity maybe to
climb up the ladder maybe there's
something wrong with our system maybe we
ought to do that so you saw that even at
that time as a youngster I remember
arguments between my father and other
people about political things like that
dealing not so much about Washington
politics but what the situation would
have to be we'd have to go to the
European route in other words either
fascism or communism because that's the
way to do things right
the New Deal for all of its historical
consequence it failed to end the Great
Depression but it did something else and
it did something I think that was part
of a very high level Visionary political
calculus that Roosevelt had in mind it
used the moment of this enduring crisis
to put in place a set of major reforms
of institutional rearrangement of the
whole social and economic landscape that
stabilized the economy once it recovered
with World War II and provided the
lattice work or the scaffolding on which
the American economy and indeed the
international economy grew like crazy
for a half century after World War II
you're always going to have boom and bus
you don't want and you may even have
panics to some degree you don't want
those to become big depressions meaning
output goes down quite a lot and then
stays down and you struggle to recover
you lose a decade you can lose a decade
and we know from the Japanese experience
recently it can happen even today in
relatively rich countries so I don't
think there should be any presumption
that we've grown out of depressions
right maybe we've learned some things
about how to avoid them maybe we haven't
I mean that that's what the discussion
should really focus on
[Music]
it was Crisis it was a meltdown
we feared that all the financial sector
Banks and security firms may go down the
Lost decade is a period of extremely low
economic growth for the Japanese economy
so the business will not doing very well
in general the sort of Norm was that
after you graduated from a college and
you
uh you go for a large farm and a large
farm will keep your whole life so you
are on the track and you can plan your
your life at the age of 22. that was a
sort of typical picture because of the
lifetime employment system they cannot
fire the core workers
so what the many Japanese companies did
during the last decade of the 1990s is
to keep the core employees that keep the
workers on the lifetime employment
system but stopped hiring
so the first hit was not the company
employees but the fresh out of college
they couldn't find you know this this
famous lifetime uh employment we made a
Lost Generation
belonging to some Community organization
it might be family or company or School
whatever
it's very important
very important and actually company
cooperation
did a very important Japanese companies
companies are heavily in charge of the
sustaining many social security or
social practically rather than
government itself
but uh you know the Lost Generation
didn't have a chance to to belong to the
academic community
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
on this net
stability of the society
or stable Healthy Growth or development
of the society we have to rebuild that
kind of community
so that's real challenge
but the answer is not getting but simply
getting back to any old system we have
to rebuild the concept of the
cooperation we have to rebuild the
concept of the employment
or labor so that's the real chance so we
really need this sort of a destructive I
mean creation
foreign
[Music]
ly see now is to avoid what happened in
Japan to avoid a lost decade here in the
United States which at this point may or
may not be unavoidable really honestly
is that we need a massive injection a
continued massive injection of economic
stimulus the question is where is this
going to come from the economy has four
basic areas that we have that drive
economic growth in the United States
about 70 percent of economic growth
comes from consumers well consumers have
declining home values declining stock
portfolios and one in ten of them nearly
is out of a job so that's really not
going to be a place where we're going to
see a lot of demand growing in the in
the short to medium term until the until
jobs come back consumption is not going
to drive our economy forward it's not
where we're going to see our recovery
and that's 70 percent of our economy so
we got to make up for that big chunk
someplace else the other three places we
can look to are business investment
export growth and government spending
businesses aren't going to invest until
they consumers so there's a little bit
of a chicken and egg problem going on
there exports are up a little bit but
still it's a relatively small share of
our overall economy so it's not clear
how that that relatively small share can
pull the whole US economy out and then
the last place we can look is in terms
of government spending to create
economic demand that's exactly what we
did during the Great Depression and it's
something that we haven't really needed
in in the same way that we need it now
at any point since the Great Depression
[Music]
foreign
I think we progress in lurches I think
we Lurch forward
I think we adopt a set of rules a
vocabulary and a standard for truth and
that serves us well this is certainly
true in science it serves us well right
up until the moment where all of a
sudden it isn't working
and the whole world comes apart
we don't know how to change it gradually
we just have to wait for the iceberg
and then a wonderful thing happens the
World falls apart
and we are able to stand there and say
what are we really trying to do here
what is our world really like one of our
most important resources in this country
is our creativity you know and that if
we can really kind of deploy that you
know I think in many respects the
answers to kind of working ourselves out
of these economic troubles may not come
from that you know the Congress or you
know or you know the House of
Representatives or you know big
corporations or the Federal Reserve but
it may be something you know things that
go on in people's garages you know
things like sustainable living tips you
know alternative currencies we're going
to see a lot of things happening on the
ground that are going to be kind of
important Innovations we're I think it's
kind of an inborn American trade that we
have a tendency to kind of tinker and
innovate when we're not happy with it
with existing or outdated systems
if you look historically a lot of strong
businesses were started during a
downturn in the economy during the Great
Depression or other recessions we've had
but I mean I was investment banker
working 90 hours a week I'd never have
the time to launch something like that
well once I got laid off
schedule opened up and I thought well
now's as good a time as any all jobs
seem to be so hard to get now that I
think you're seeing people really just
go after where their passions are as
opposed to well this is where the money
is
so I think you're seeing a number of
Paradigm shifts more so than before and
value shifting values I think and and I
My Hope Is that they'll last so that
we'll have
that there'll be more of a gap between
these these boom and bus periods and so
we'll see if you'll tend to have short
memories I think particularly when times
do start to turn around
Welcome to New York City Financial
Capital role welcome to Wall Street the
heart of American capitalism I was a
former vice president at Deutsche Bank
they're a help manage a billion dollar
trading business the crisis displaces a
lot of people you know I lost my job
you know it's Adam Smith Invisible Hand
of smacking me around and putting me to
a different area of the economy but for
me you know I'm really happy with what
I'm doing now showing people Wall Street
telling my story I love to teach some
people uh find inspiration you know
they're saying hey here's a guy making
lemonade on a limit you know other
people say
you know hey here's a Trader that's been
downgraded to a tour guide you know it's
two different ways to look at it
years ago I was fully infiltrated in the
financial industry which I loved and
adored and had been doing since I
graduated from college
and as time passed I started to see
everything going on in the financial
markets just huge blow-ups I then in
fact got my pink slip and ended up being
laid off
and I often remember my mom saying like
the farm is what saved her parents
during the Depression they also did like
crazy stuff like you know sell moonshine
I guess and you know like how's
different people coming over from Europe
that need extra housing and put them up
but always kind of like thinking of
different ways of
smart and making money and and saving
their money I worked really hard in
finance but I'm working a lot harder now
than I ever worked in finance you know
for for nothing basically you're you
know hopefully I do have potentially
attained something but it's a return to
intelligence and creativity and you know
this emergence of young entrepreneurs
with socially conscious types of
businesses were all kind of like
bartering with one another of how to get
work done and how to you know get a
fashion show done with no Capital while
this person needs this exposure and I
need this and let's like figure out a
way to make this happen so yeah it's an
interesting time and it's it's also like
something great to be a part of I feel
thing my husband saying uh it was so
cheap
that once he took the kids and me out
for coffee and donuts
kids loved it because they had never
given blood before
foreign
that's a beautiful joke
in retrospect
it may look like a great thing that
happened that was a necessity
get us back on the track properly
because after all we each of us are a
part of human evolution
and we take with us technology
and we're speeding into the universe
your experience that you had coming
through those times sustain you
they make you strong
you're tested in a crucible of a fire
the depression beat people down
so there's wonderful and romantically to
say look at how these people
pull themselves up and made something of
themselves but there's also that other
half of the population that couldn't do
that that were so beaten down by the
depression
that it it affected their mindset and
people around them and their families
for years and years to come so unless
you have that courage to keep on and
those early days and the depression days
molded a lot of people
he gave them the courage and the
strength to become somebody
I would not say it makes us stronger I
would say it makes us free
it makes us more confident when it's all
over it makes us confident in our
ability to survive that part of it is
true but it doesn't make our beliefs
stronger it usually destroys them it
doesn't make our family systems stronger
it usually injures them it doesn't make
our economic systems stronger or our
political systems stronger it usually
wrecks it so I don't think in those
senses that it made us stronger I think
what it did was force us to think freely
and Anew about our lives and the way
we're going to judge truth the way we
communicate to each other the people
we're willing to trust and not trust I
think it's a moment of Enlightenment now
it's usually accompanied by nausea
we're so often saved In Spite of
Ourselves you know the something Arnold
toyanby a great historian said that his
lifelong study and he was no mystic he
was a very practical man he said his
lifelong study of history had led him to
the conclusion that every time the
puddle of human Affairs was about to
congeal completely the Finger of God
comes down and stirs us and I thought it
seems like that sometimes one of the
beauties of that period was that though
we had no
money of any Lord except for that small
upper fibers
six percent of the population who were
jumping out of Windows committing
suicide because he couldn't take it we
had ways to take it
and that again is the
factor that
is a part of American Life an American
Dream is that
we can take it because it's going to get
better
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign